PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
In the last episode,
we learned about TFX, which
helps us engineer our machine
learning pipeline
so we can deploy
our models in production.
Are you ready to see
it all in action?
Let's go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to A.I.
Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and today I'm
going to show you how to manage
a production machine learning
pipeline using TFX.
For this, we are going
to use the Chicago Taxi
Dataset, available in BitQuery.
And the goal of our model
is to predict if customers
tip more or less than 20%.
So it is a binary
classification problem.
Here's what we will do.
First, we will set up our
environment on Google Cloud.
Then we'll set up and deploy
A.I. pipelines on a Kubernetes
cluster using Kubeflow.
Then, we set up Cloud A.I.
Platform, Notebook Instance,
and work in the notebook
to run the pipeline.
We hop into the
Google Cloud console
and create an A.I.
platform pipeline cluster.
Configure the Kubeflow pipeline.
Make sure to allow
access to the Cloud APIs.
This is an important
step for the cluster
to access other
pieces of our project.
Once the cluster is created,
we deploy the pipeline.
Now we open our pipeline
dashboard and the TF notebook.
We create a new
notebook instance here.
You can change the machine type
here to a faster processing
machine, but remember that
there's a cost associated
with your choice.
Now we are in our notebook.
The first step is to install TFX
and Kubeflow pipeline packages.
Downloading Scaffold
module, we then
set the path to include user
Python binary directory,
and a directory
containing Scaffold.
Then we check which version
of TFX is installed.
And then set the project ID
as the environment variable.
Set the Kubeflow
cluster endpoint,
and then we set the name
for the custom Docker
image of our pipeline.
And now we set the
name of our pipeline
and copy the pipeline template
into the project directory.
Today, for this example, we're
using Chicago Taxi Dataset
to perform binary
classification.
So the template sets
the model to taxi.
As a result of this command,
in the file browser,
we see a basic
scaffold of files that
build a pipeline, including
pipeline source codes, sample
data, and Jupyter notebooks.
Now, if you're working
on a different problem,
these files might look
a little bit different.
Here, let's see what
these files are.
Pipeline directory contains
the definition of the pipeline.
configs.py the common constants
for the pipeline runners.
pipeline.py defines
the TFX components,
and a pipeline models
directory contains the machine
learning model definitions.
features.py and features_test.py
defines the met features
of the model.
preprocessing.py and
preprocessing_test.py defines
feature engineering
using TFX transform.
Estimated directory contains
an estimator-based model.
Inside that, constants.py
defines constants of the model,
and model.py and model_test.py
defines the DNN model using
the TensorFlow estimator.
Keras directory contains
a Keras-based model,
which is constants.py
file, defines the constants
of the model, and the model.py
and model_test.py defines
the DNN model using Keras.
Kubeflow_dag_runner file defines
runners for each orchestration
engine.
This example includes both
an estimator-based model
and a Keras-based
model for reference.
So you should choose
whichever one is best for you.
Now, before we run our
TFX pipeline on Kubeflow,
we first need somewhere to
store the artifacts that
will be created when
we run the pipeline.
These artifacts are
called payloads,
and we will use Google
Cloud Storage to store them.
We copy our sample data
to GCS, and then we
create the pipeline.
This will generate a
Docker file and build.yaml
to build a Docker image.
Make sure to add these files
to your source code system,
for example, Git, along
with other source files.
Now we are ready to run
our TFX pipeline using
the TFX run create command.
We can also see this run under
experiments in the Kubeflow
pipelines dashboard.
Now, the first task in any data
science or machine learning
project is to understand
and clean the data.
ExampleGen ingests and
splits the input data set.
StatisticsGen calculates
statistics for the data set.
SchemaGen examines
the statistics
and creates a data schema.
Example Validator looks for the
anomalies and missing values
inside the data set.
In the pipeline.py file, we
will enable these components
and update the
pipeline for a rerun.
After the rerun, we can see our
pipeline in the visual format.
And after understanding
the data and cleaning it,
the next step is to transform to
increase the predictive quality
of our data, and reduce the
dimensionality and feature
engineering.
After transforming the data,
we use the Trainer component
of the TFX to train our model.
Then we would run Evaluator
to perform deep analysis
of the training results.
And then we use the Pusher
component to deploy the model
to a serving infrastructure.
I enabled all these
in the pipeline.py,
and the resulting pipeline,
with all the components,
looks like this in the
Kubeflow dashboard.
Depending on the requirements
of your workload,
your pipeline might need
more CPU, GPUs, or memory.
To modify these, I have included
the documentation below.
Now that we know how
the TFX pipeline works,
you might be wondering
how we can directly use
BigQuery as the data source.
There's a component
called BigQuery Example
Gen that connects to BigQuery
in a specified Google Cloud
project.
TFX inter-operates
with several other
managed Google Cloud Services,
such as Cloud Dataflow.
Several TFX components
use Apache Beam
to implement data
parallel pipelines,
and it means that you can
distribute data processing
workloads using Cloud Dataflow.
TFX also interoperates
with Cloud A.I. Platform
for training and prediction.
You can set your
Trainer component
to use Cloud A.I.
Platform training, which
is a managed service for
training machine learning
models.
And when your model is built
and ready to be served,
you can push your model to
Cloud A.I. Platform Prediction
for serving.
In this video, we
just created, and ran,
a machine learning
pipeline, and visualized
the results of each run.
Give TFX a try yourself
with a different data
set, and let me know how it
goes in the comments below.
If you like this
video, and would
like to see more such content,
give us a like and subscribe.